can you imagine taking down that many
hot dogs i practice but i get to like
one hot dog and then you're like i'm
sorry i'm done i guess i won't win i
guess i won't win it you got to wet the
bun no that's not happening
we're going to be eating hot dogs fourth
of july it's a hot dog weekend
we should look at how many hot dogs get
sold this weekend because yes it is a
barbecue weekend there's going to be a
little bit of wind to deal with but
we've seen winds stronger than what
we're going to see over the weekend so
that's the good news right i don't think
there are going to be any wind
advisories issued live look outside
right now this top this is our camera
look at the las vegas strip you can see
the background there clear skies
cloud-free skies like what we saw
earlier this week where we had clouds
and we had also
even some showers around the region 103
outside right now there's humidity only
at seven percent that's how dry it is
after double digit sticky readings
earlier this week 103 centennial hills
97 for someone right now we're 106 for
you downtown 104 for green valley and
105 for henderson you're at the century
mark rhodes ranch and mountains edge
temperatures are pretty much similar to
what we saw yesterday not warmer than
yesterday or not even cooler 100 for
prop 112 for death valley 104 for
boulder city so here's our radar network
dry here look at that but you go east
again and we're getting some pop-up
storms right around flagstaff that's
where they seem to be staying and will
stay also over the weekend so as we zoom
out you'll notice drier air working its
way in from the west look at the whole
southwest here from
vegas all the way towards the west we'll
start to see
things really drying out breezy winds
also are going to be around with that
southwest flow and that will continue
over the weekend we think they will peak
look at this on sunday they could be up
to 35 or more than that over the weekend
on sunday and then they'll drop a little
more for monday that is july 4th so it
will be breezy still on july 4th however
i think those winds will peak on the 4th
in the afternoon as we get to the
evening on your 4th of july 4th cast
there's a look at your evening
temperatures in the 90s this time around
93 at 8 pm notice those winds still a
little breezy at times for the evening
again we've seen winds stronger than
that it will be breezy but we're not
looking for those strong gusty ones we
see some from some big storms in the
past 81 degrees overnight breezy and
clear tomorrow your high 103 similar to
today more breezy heat and temperature
our wind gusts could get up to 35 again
for tomorrow here's your recreation
forecast because i know a lot of you
want to get out this weekend head to the
mountain 75 degrees up there nice and
cool but remember we will keep those
winds elevated for the weekend red
rock's still going to be hot 97 degrees
so drink plenty of water bring a big
bottle of water with you 108 for the
lake tomorrow breezy and extra hot waves
will be choppy so please if you're going
to be on the water on the boat where the
life is please all right eight day
forecast shows that wind over the
weekend and early next week drop in 98
and then oh yeah the big heat returns
later on the week next week that's your
most accurate weather update